Hello. Good afternoon.
I'm Ora Lassila, and I will
be talking about
graph abstractions.
This is titled as
a personal view,
mostly because I'm
kind of talking
about things that I've been
thinking about for
several years now.
Not only in the context of my
current position
as a principal
technologist in
the Amazon Neptune
graph database team,
but also throughout the work
that I've done
with with RDF and
the Symantec Web over the past
more than twenty years.
So here is a rough
game plan today.
I'll talk a little bit about
the history of graphs first,
and then I'll get into graph
abstractions and
and really how
to access graph data
from the software
standpoint. From that,
I'll go to treating an entire
graph as an abstraction
and talk
a little bit about what we can
do to unify
the currently somewhat
fragmented world of graphs.
And, I'll conclude with,
some thoughts about how to how
to move forward from
the current state.
So this is my take on,
on on the history
of graphs and
ontologies.
Oftentimes, these things are
presented as something new and
the reality is quite
the opposite.
So if we look at the graphs,
graph theory as a branch of
mathematics dates
back to the early
seventeen hundreds.
And ever since the,
the birth of computer science
as a as a field of study,
we've understood
that graphs are
really
the essential underpinning
for most of computer science.
Social networks
showed up sometime
in the 1960s.
Things like the small
world experiment,
six degrees of
separation, and and,
something we call
the Erdos number.
And then in throughout
the sixties
and seventies, there was work
on on network databases or
navigational
databases and then
semantic networks,
which is really where we're
starting to spill
over to the ontology
side here.
If we look at
ontologies, really,
we can go back to
the third century BC,
and Aristotle's
work on categories
and logic. Of course,
the whole idea of taxonomical
classification of things,
got more concrete in the early
seventeen hundreds
when Linnaeus
classified plants
and animals.
In late eighteen hundreds,
we saw work on
library classification
in the form of the Dewey
classification system.
And then around
nineteen hundred,
philosopher Edmund
Husserl really
worked on sort
of understanding
how ontology can
be the foundation
for representing
information and
the meaning of information.
Now fast forward to the 1970s
and onwards.
Predicate logic became sort of
the foundation of knowledge
representation in
the field of AI.
And then in the late 90s is
where these things
come together
in the inception
of the semantic
web and the related standards
such as RDF and
OWL and whatnot.
And from that,
we basically get
the modern knowledge
graphs and
graph databases and all that.
So long history.
But despite this history,
programming with graphs and
ontologies is by
and large still
rather cumbersome.
And this is something,
I'd like to address.
So, when we're talking about
graphs today, we first of all
have this a little bit of
fragmentation of the space.
And and and this may be all
familiar to all of you,
but let me just
kind of summarize,
anyway. So we
basically have two
kinds of graphs,
RDF graphs and labeled
property graphs.
On the RDF side,
graphs are such that vertices
and edge types are really just
identifiers. Graphs decompose
into something we
call triples.
So basically,
these are the edges
and the two
endpoints of an edge.
Scalar data types in RDF are
pulled from XSD, XML schema.
And there are no
composite data
types per se, and composite
objects are constructed using
the graph structure itself.
Now, on the property
graph side,
vertices and edges themselves
are structured objects.
There is no common identifier
scheme like there is
on the RDF side.
And the scalar and
composite data types,
they are typically
borrowed from
the whatever is
the implementation
language underneath.
We also have
fragmentation when
it comes to query languages.
So on the RDF side,
we have SPARQL.
And in the context
of this talk,
on the property graph side,
we have Gremlin and Cypher.
There are others too,
because the field is
more fragmented.
I'll be talking
about RDF mostly.
Towards the end,
I'll come back to
property graphs.
If we look at RDF
and the abstractions
available for us in terms of
programming with
graphs, The triples,
which RDF graphs
decomposed to,
are very low level
abstractions.
It's like programming with
assembly language.
So we need something
different.
And in the past,
we've sort of tried
to map graphs
to trees,
but we have a meta
model mismatch there.
Graphs and trees,
there there are differences
which can cause all
kinds of confusion.
And of course,
examples of this
are things like RDF XML,
You're trying to use XML as
the representation
for RDF and JSON LD,
which is basically
does the same
with JSON.
I think of those as
warning examples.
Now, of course,
it's also important
to remember
that really when it
comes to graph,
the syntax does not matter and
it should not matter.
You solve the syntax
problem once,
and then you forget about it.
But what about the graph
abstractions themselves?
So could we do something that
people have done on
the relational side?
So something that
could be like
an object graph mapping?
Take data from a graph and map
that to some kind of objects.
There are it can be
done, of course,
but there are some interesting
issues here. So first of all,
what constitutes an object?
So how much of
the graph do you
have to pull to
build an object?
And then, of course,
there are these kind of shared
references. And in
RDF particularly,
there's something
called blank nodes.
These are nodes that cannot be
addressed from
outside the graph
and those can be difficult to
handle if you do this mapping
to objects.
Graph queries,
or as I'd like to
sort of think about,
this, how do I get
there from here?
So graph queries, mostly,
they're about
traversal in the sense
that traversal is an excellent
way to understand what you do
with a graph and how you kind
of find things in a graph.
So questions like where can I
go from here given
this particular
path pattern?
Are these two
nodes in the graph
connected? And if they are,
how are they connected?
Using path patterns,
for traversing
a graph is a little
bit like pattern
matching the graph
itself. And of course,
SPARQL is a very
powerful query
language, but it's
a very big hammer,
very heavy tool for most graph
access problems.
We need something simpler.
Something like
a simple search,
maybe faceted
search or filtering
of data from the graph.
And once you've done
the filtering,
then of course
the question is,
give me everything you know.
to the particular
node in the graph.
This is sort of
related to the object
graph mapping. And
then, of course,
queries that really
are about traversal,
specifically. So
specifically.
Now, graphs are
the graph data,
graphs they're
modeled somehow.
And here again, we
have some problems.
So first of all,
the property graphs generally
do not have schema languages
that would let you
do the modeling.
So the model is
implicit or it's
buried in the code
that you write.
RDF, on the other hand,
in some ways has
too many schema
languages. So, we have RDFS,
we have OWL as a sort of more
powerful schema language,
and then we have
SHACL and they
are all languages that were
created really for
specific purposes.
And I think there,
what we would
need is some kind
of a unifying view of these
because telling
people that, hey,
you can model your graph,
but here are three schema
languages that
you have to use.
It's just confusing.
And then the third problem,
and then maybe
the most important
problem is that
how do you then
take models of your graph data
and map those to
whatever it is
that you have to
do when you're
writing code?
There's also this question of
shared ontologies
or shared models.
So let's say you have decided
to use some shared
ontology and
you map your data to this
particular ontology.
Now what?
What does that
actually buy you?
How do you take advantage of
the fact that your data now
conforms to
a particular model?
So here I'm sort
of pondering,
can we support ontologies with
some kind of
predefined software
libraries that basically
encapsulates some
of the knowledge
about this ontology.
And I like to call
these ontology
engines. This is ongoing work
on my part.
And then finally,
since we're talking
about ontologies,
there's the question
of reasoning,
which is really
something we can
do on the RDF side,
particularly.
First of all, we have symbolic
reasoning. So this is really
reasoning using some type of
logical rules.
Interesting things
to to to note
here is that
generative reasoning
or reasoning that kind of adds
more edges to the graph,
if you will,
is something that
can easily be
hidden from
the application itself.
The application actually does
not have to know that there's
a reasoner running
underneath.
Queries and accesses
to the graph
are really not to the asserted
graph itself,
but they are to the graph plus
all the things that we have
managed to infer
from the graph.
Then, of course,
we have non symbolic
reasoning.
So machine learning techniques
can actually be used much like
symbolic reasoning.
You can do things like node
classification or
link prediction.
And I think what
we really need
is sort of an expanded view of
reasoning where
we will kind of
stop this sort of rift between
symbolic reasoning and non
symbolic reasoning.
But I think more importantly,
what we really
need to do is we
need to rethink what
an application is.
I think that logic should be
associated with the data and
the models and not
with an application.
Traditional view
of an application
is that it's sort
of the gatekeeper
to particular kind of data.
And I think
a better view of of
an application is
that it reflects
the user's intent to,
accomplish something.
But in this view,
you really have to kind of
separate the application from
the semantics of the data.
I think graphs really could be
sort of an overarching logical
abstraction for all the data
that we manipulate.
Modern enterprise
data practices,
to be, to put this kindly,
is messy and data silos,
they're commonplace.
And data integration
often happens
through ad hoc
solutions or just
a custom integration
scripts or
what have you. And this thing
will never end unless we find
some kind of
a unifying logical
not only manipulating the data
from the standpoint
of our software,
not only manipulating the data
from the standpoint of our of
our software applications,
but also from
the standpoint of
data integration.
My view of this is that until
something better shows up,
RDF and OWL actually
can provide
this view.
I chose this picture
here specifically.
This is the Tower of Babel.
And I think that that's where
we are when it comes to data
practice today.
Lots of languages,
everybody's talking,
nobody's understanding.
And then, of course,
we still have this question of
RDF versus the labeled
property graph,
so let me talk a little
bit about that.
First of all, when users are
given the choice
between RDF and
property graphs,
it tends to confuse users.
They don't know what to choose
and once they make
that choice,
it tends to be
hard to walk back
that choice later
on if you find
out you made
the wrong choice.
This really should
not matter.
I think the real
issue here deep
down maybe that
there are these
two kind of ways to
think about graphs.
Graph as
a logical representation
of your data versus
graph as a physical
data structure.
I think RDF tends to represent
the former, property graphs
often the latter.
But regardless of this,
the practical problem we face
is that we still
have two separate
ecosystems for
tooling for these
two different
kinds of graphs.
So let's talk
a little bit about
these graphs, RDF and
property graphs.
What are the pros and
what are the cons?
So RDF is a W3C standard.
It's well established,
originally created over twenty
years ago.
RDF makes it easy
to use external
data sources.
RDF comes with schema
languages And,
particularly when it comes to
external data sources,
RDF has formal semantics,
and it particularly has formal
semantics for graph merging.
And then finally,
RDF supports reasoning.
So you can
incorporate symbolic
reasoning in your
application.
Property graphs on the other
side are very intuitive for
software more so than RDF.
And they tend to
integrate better
with programming languages,
particularly when it comes to
the query language Grambling,
which in a way sort
of is a programming
language in its own right.
Now on the negative
side, for RDF,
it's often considered kind of
too academic. I
don't necessarily
share this view myself,
but this is what
I keep hearing.
And related to that is that
there's no kind
of easy on ramp
to learn and adopt RDF.
Now, on the property graphs,
on the negative side is that
there is no standard.
There's many
divergent implementations
that are proprietary.
There's no schema language and
there is no formal semantics.
So this makes it
hard to do a lot
of things and I'll
come back to that.
So this is the reality,
but what we really
want is we want both.
We want the good
things from RDF
and we want the good
things from
property graphs.
And we don't want
to be confused
with the choice
between the two.
So this sort of brings me back
to the idea that
the graph itself
is sort of an abstraction.
What we really
want is a unifying
model that covers both RDF and
the property graphs. Why?
Because this would
help adoption
of graph technology
and I think
this is important to
the graph industry,
if you will. It's
still sort of
a nascent industry
and to really
see mainstream adoption,
we need to make things easier
and less confusing.
It also gives
users more choices
if we were to have this.
So for example,
I personally would very much
like to run Gremlin over RDF,
but today I can't do that.
So in the Neptune
team, at AWS,
we're working on this,
in a project code
named OneGraph.
And turns out that this is
actually not so easy.
There are a number
of obstacles.
We think we can solve them,
but let me just
kind of give you
the highlights of what things
are difficult.
So first of all,
there's the question
of the formal
semantics of RDF and also this
emerging extension
of RDF called
RDF star that
tries to bring RDF
closer to how property
graphs work.
In RDF semantics,
triples are unique,
which means that
that you can't
have two triples
that are the same
but would be separate so that
you could assign different
properties to them.
Whereas this is a very common
pattern in property graphs.
And of course,
those of you who
know RDF,
there's the old
style verification
mechanism, for this,
and it does not
have this problem,
but verification tends to be
cumbersome and is
often misunderstood.
I think it's
the most misunderstood
part of the original
RDF specification.
There's, of course,
this question of
lack of formal
semantics for
property graphs.
It's kind of difficult to
determine what the correct
semantics are. And so building
this unifying and
unifying model,
it's now difficult because we
don't actually know how to
reconcile RDF semantics and
property graph semantics.
On the property graph side,
there's also kind
of a diversity
of scalar, scalar data types,
which would have
to be reconciled
against the set of scalar data
types on the RDS.
There's question of
graph partitioning.
So RDF supports a mechanism
called named graphs that lets
you partition your graph.
This mechanism does not exist
on the property graph side.
Now, to make things even more
complicated is that in RDF,
vertices are just
identifiers.
There's no structure.
So when you're
partitioning your graph,
you're really kind
of what you're
doing is that you're you're
asking which
particular partition
does any particular
edge belong to.
But on the property
graph side,
both vertices and edges are
structured objects.
So what do you do
about the partitioning
when it comes to vertices?
And then finally,
there's this
question of update
semantics. So to come back to
the first problem,
so let's say we have these non
unique triples.
So kind of multiple instances
of the same edge,
if you will.
When you delete one of them,
what happens to the others?
Are those deleted as well?
We have to figure
out what the right
semantics for that is.
And then, of course,
if you have
properties on edges,
so you've associated some
properties with
the edges themselves,
What happens when you delete
such an edge? Are
those properties
deleted as well?
So would we need some kind of
a cascading delete
for edge properties?
All these are problems that we
have to solve
before we can say
that we can have this
unifying model.
But anyway, we're
working on this,
we're getting there.
So, the way forward,
and this I really
would like to
present in terms of what are
the real pain points when it
comes to building knowledge
graph software.
So first of all is
the basic question,
how do I write software that
leverages knowledge graph and
knowledge graph data?
We have to kind
of bridge the gap
between the graph
and the code.
Your graph has a model,
your code needs to understand
what that model is,
how do you do that?
And as I said earlier,
we have these very low level
interfaces to graphs,
and that basically means that
you end up writing a lot of
boilerplate code.
So I think the answer is that
we really need to
think carefully
what the proper interfaces and
abstractions are for graphs.
So the second
question is, okay,
so I map my data
to an ontology.
Now what? So,
what does it mean to have some
kind of support
for ontologies?
What is the role
of reasoning?
As I said, hiding
the reasoning
works well and
and and there are
some things that you can pick
from RDF and AL that are
particularly useful.
But how do you do this?
At this point, I'm thinking
libraries built to
support a particular
ontology might be the answer.
Like I said earlier,
I call these ontology engines
so that you
basically have some
software support if you decide
to adopt a particular ontology
that you use for
modeling your data.
So then there's
the question of
property graphs versus RDF.
What do we do about those?
Choosing between
the two is hard.
It leads to confusion.
We have this effort,
the RDF star effort that is
going to offer some
alleviation to this,
this problem,
but may not get us
quite quite there.
For that, the OneGraph Unified
Meta Model should
bring a relief.
And, we recently
published a paper
on this and, I'll
have the link
to that at the end of
the presentation.
And then finally,
there's this question of,
can we get out
of this practice
of never ending integrations
between data that
sits in silos.
Modern tools we have do not
actually offer
a single unified
view of data.
And I do believe that graphs,
particularly built on built on
RDF and OWL modeling,
can offer this unifying
logical view.
And that doesn't
mean there has
to be a physical
view of the data.
But we need some
common language
to talk about data so that we
can talk about
integrations and
we can kind of separate
the applications
from the physical data.
So those are my
thoughts today.
I'm happy to take
questions and
here are some links,
some material
about how to build
knowledge graphs
on using Neptune
and then this
paper of ours that
talks about
the unifying model,
between RDF and
Propertures. Thank you.